now is this right am I correct you are
half Irish is that correct that's right
um I am half Irish my mother is actually
Black Irish
um but she was adopted by like a real
Irish not the Black Irish isn't real
Irish but another Irish family and
they're like really Irish like they're
really going for it they have like red
hair and they're the rallies and they
kind of raised me so it was kind of it
was kind of awesome because I was kind
of thrown in I'm half Puerto Rican too
and I was kind of like thrown in with
this like huge uh Irish family and I
would have to do whatever they did and
which included Irish dancing what um
they made you I mean I'm from a big
large Irish family we never did Irish
dancing they did Irish dancing yeah I
competed in Irish dancing uh
competitions I was the only dark-haired
spicy Puerto Rican
Focus competitions but what kind of
dances are we talking about
Irish
like that Lord of the Dance Like the
Lord of the Dance thing where they keep
their legs straight their shoes I don't
know why I'm doing this in an office
chair how is that proving anything I I
to be honest the only one I remember is
the sevens that was like the beginner
one I was really bad at it and the
teacher was always like smoking and she
was like shoving me around and yelling
at me but I do remember the sevens that
may not have been a dance class
yeah it was like hop one two three hop
two two three right but I haven't had to
use that yet I have it in my back pocket
if I get attacked by an angry drunk mob
I need to now stay back I understand you
are you are the sevens sorry is this
thing on no it's no it doesn't even work
just get rid of that we don't need this
uh it's fine ladies and gentlemen calm
yourselves
floating out to the Sea right now
I understand you're quite a good athlete
is that right oh yes what's your sport I
play basketball people ask me about this
a lot because I don't uh look like I'd
be good at basketball but I'm pretty
damn good at basketball
do you always time your sip just when
you say that
no
all right that was bad so you uh you
play basketball why are you so good what
makes you so good you just started
playing young I'm not like that good I'm
good
you just said you I'm really good I'm
pretty good okay I'm really great I'm
good I'm just like I'm not I'm not
amazing but I'm pretty good and
um I play with you know just random
people and I really like it for the
strategy when I was in high school I
played for my church basketball league
and um and I was the point guard and I
used to come up with like interesting
versions of plays instead of being like
that I'd be like sacrament of
reconciliation
and then
we're gonna do a thing or like the blood
of Christ which means like throw the
ball to the corner and then
seated at the right hand of the father
so come again
wow that's
I wish I had played with you guys yeah
we were really good
yeah me